el presidente francés Emmanuel macrón ya
está en China donde pasará los próximos
tres días con una doble finalidad por un
lado estrechar las relaciones económicas
para lo cual se ha hecho acompañar de
una nutrida representación de 60
empresarios y por el otro intentar
convencer a China para que contribuya a
acabar con la guerra en Ucrania gracias
a su buena sintonía con Rusia china
puede jugar un buen papel en el camino
hacia la paz ha dicho hoy macron el
presidente francés se reunirá mañana con
su homólogo chino y ambos partirán al
día siguiente hacia la provincia sureña
de One Esta visita forma parte de la
iniciativa diplomática China de
recuperar el tiempo perdido después del
parón de casi tres años por la política
del cero covid Y es que la diplomacia
china vive en un Frenesí en apenas unos
meses habrán pasado por aquí entre otros
el presidente de España Alemania y
Francia y los más altos dirigentes de
las instituciones europeas ese afán de
China por estrechar los lazos que en
Europa contrasta con el desdén por
recomponer la comunicación con Estados
Unidos después del escándalo del
supuesto globo espía a Pekín le urge por
un lado alejar a Bruselas de la línea
hostil de Washington y por el otro sumar
adeptos para su plan de paz para Ucrania
lo segundo no va a ser nada fácil el
presidente español Pedro Sánchez Ya dijo
aquí la semana pasada que el plan que
apoyaba era el de Ucrania porque era el
que estaba conforme a la carta de las
Naciones Unidas y la presidenta de la
comisión usa la ponderline que está esta
semana con macron en Pekín calificó el
plan de paz chino de inviable